[Music]
I'm gonna start how's it going hey hey
I'm gonna start with 222 and then we'll
go to 59 hi
thanks thanks to Mike please
congratulations first team from Bulgaria
could you tell us more about the process
how you embody the character how you
started working on that role oh it's so
boring
but if you want to hear it I can tell
you the whole you know it's like a big
souffle or a stew you know some potatoes
and some carrots in there and it's kind
of you work with a amazing dialect coach
like Liz Himelstein who worked with gary
oldman and margo and Terry Knickerbocker
my acting coach and I did some
ride-alongs with some cops
Josh McMullen in southern Missouri
Liz Himelstein taped two cops actually
there was a guy named emer in LA I did a
ride-along with him and I met with a
skin graft doctor who introduced me to
some burn victims actually I mean I but
the thing is that's if you have luxury
the luxury of time you know which you
don't always have for a part and and and
then I worked with Martin and but
sometimes you get apart and you only
have a week or a couple days to prepare
I heard that jeremy renner only had four
days to prepare to play Jeffrey Dahmer
which is a lot if you're playing Jeffrey
Dahmer you know so I had the advantage
that I had like two or three months and
so I got to indulge in all this research
and so it was a lot of fun so that's it
that's the long answer to your short
question
we're gonna go to 59 and then 134 Matt
figure home roger ebert calm hey you
said a wonderful thing about the arc of
your character being Barney Fife going
into trap yes yes I'd love to ask in any
way it was Travis was a Barney Fife and
the great Don Knotts any inspiration
here as an actor throughout your career
absolutely I mean I mean that when I say
Barney Fife and you know the town of
Epping is very much like Mayberry
and Woody Harrelson's character is very
much like the Andy Griffith character
and in fact I could be wrong about this
check your facts but I think we shot in
Sylva North Carolina I think Mayberry
was shot there but I could be wrong
about that
but you know the the goofiness of Barney
Fife the the kind of hapless thing of
Barney Fife and then his transition into
into somebody else was just sort of
Travis Bickle was kind of a Barney Fife
Travis Bickle was kind of a
generalization but um it's it's a lot
more complicated than that obviously but
you know yeah
going over to 134 and then 16 in the
back I say I'm over here other side hey
oh there you go it's your left in the
back okay hey you dedicated your win to
Phil Hoffman and I would just oh you
caught that good we could hear that you
heard that yes cuz I thought the music
was going oh good I'm glad you heard
that yeah so I'm curious like as a
friend and as a colleague chunk tell me
you know what he meant to you how he
inspired you well I guess you want to
start making me cry but he's yeah he was
an old friend of mine and he directed me
in a play at the Public Theater and yeah
he was very close to me and he was an
inspiration to all of my peers you know
people like Jeffrey Wright Billy Crudup
Liev Schreiber you know you know
everybody that in Mark Ruffalo Josh
Brolin I mean whoever was in my age
range Phil Hoffman was the guy and he
was a great director and he believed in
in doing theater in fact he was avowed
to do a play a year which I don't know
if he got to do but because he was very
busy doing movies but he was a great
inspiration and a great theater director
and I don't know if anybody knows he was
he was a bit of a jock he was a wrestler
and he played basketball and he inspired
me and I could go on for an hour about
Phil Hoffman Philip Seymour Hoffman was
a good friend and he was a huge huge
inspiration on me yeah thank you
we're going to 60 and then we'll come to
198 somewhere in the back - you're right
you're right
oh yeah alright okay hey Intel for
America how you doing you know I stopped
counting at 21 the awards that you want
before the Academy Awards
so did you count them at all I'm sorry I
say you say one more time I stopped
counting one
yeah words that you want so do you count
them at all yeah do you feel that those
were like people's saying some you're
gonna win your scars no but that sounds
like a really cool dream but no no going
over to 198 and then I'm gonna have to
wrap it up salute to 11 what's up man
Steve bird from horsey 2 FM and
obviously they liked your hair dude ah
thank you very much obviously very proud
of Martin because we hail from Ireland
so Saoirse and Saoirse as well car teen
sleep tonight Colin and in Bruges yeah
loads exactly as a frequent collaborator
obviously now of Martin what is it about
him that makes him such a great artist
well you know he says Martin says that
you know you couldn't set this in
Ireland or England or but I actually
think you could set this movie in almost
any working-class town and over all over
the world but I he disagrees with that
but I I think you could it could be
anywhere almost but there is obviously
something very timely about it now
what's going on in this country you know
yeah and we're gonna wrap it up right
here with 2:11
hi James blue hey how you doing PBS
Newshour hey uh there's been some
complaint criticism about the film yes
specifically as it relates to after the
betrayal and the relationships with
african-americans yeah talk about
specifically your character and whether
you take that criticism on or how you
dealt with it and your sense of that
well yeah I mean it's a it's a
complicated issue but I mean Kareem
abdul-jabbar wrote an article that was
really amazing sort of defending the
movie and as far as that goes
and it was really eloquent I didn't
realize he's like he's like a cultural
professor which I didn't know and
in addition to being like a basketball
icon and that was a great article that
articulated everything and I think for
me you know the whole thing is that you
know they have a lot of work to do
the Mildred and Dixon it's not like
they're like all of a sudden redeemed at
the end of the movie they they have you
know a lot of work to do and maybe some
therapy you know it's it's it's an
ongoing thing you know so that's also
it's a it's a it's a movie and it's a
it's a dark fairy tale of some sorts and
so it's like it's it's not necessarily
in real life we probably would have gone
to prison both of our characters so you
know that's that's sort of how I I see
it thank you so much and congratulations
thanks thanks a lot
[Applause]